and on the final week of what's been an
arm down election campaign for him I'm
joined by the brexit party leader Nigel
Farage say more very much for being with
us today now before we get onto your own
and campaign just want to start with the
interview that we did with Boris Johnson
where he says he wants to see in
Australia style points based immigration
heard that before must be listening to
you yeah I said I've been saying this
for years that we should not be
discriminating against people coming
from other parts of the world in favor
of the European Union and you do it on a
skills base you also differentiate
between settlement and work permits and
yes you're right they're beginning to
say the same things the problem is
they'll make no real commitment to cut
the numbers coming in and this is the
fourth conservative manifesto in a row
promising to reduce numbers I mean he
guarantee that numbers would come down
when I sat down with him I don't come on
this is the same Boris Johnson do twice
as publicly called for mass amnesties
for illegal immigrants I mean we could
have a little look to something else
that he told me about immigration in
that interview and the prime minister
saying I'm a believer in allowing people
to come into this country if they have
talents and they want to do things and
make their lives in the UK and they can
contribute to our economy fantastic and
we've benefited from that so how does it
how does he square that with calling for
amnesties for hundreds of thousands of
illegal immigrants Boris Johnson has
always been very soft on the immigration
issue but you know what there's an
election on so tell people what they
want to hear because it's effective
promising what you want to see on
immigration he's promising do you get
brexit done why on earth should anyone
vote for the brexit huh there you are
so that's why even though I you know
it's very difficult to trust him and
believe in being a he said not just that
but he also said that we would go for a
Canada style trade deal which of course
would mean a proper break with the
institutions of the European Union now I
have to say he did rather backtrack on
that in the debate on Friday by talking
about the oven-ready deal which I feel
would give us that's the exit hasn't
negotiated betrayed what no no no the
exit deal binds us in that's the point
unless the exit Deal is amended we will
be stuck in regulator alignment for
years to come but but but but either way
it's an opportunity to diverge
if you negate the train deal we know you
can't do you can't do that
what we're doing here and and and you
know it's called the brexit election and
you guys have branded it that from the
start we've had no discussion at all in
this campaign about what the brexit deal
is it is a new EU treaty if it goes
through an amended we will find it
virtually impossible to make trade deals
with any other part of the world and we
will find ourselves in everything from
financial services to fisheries bound by
EU law but there is still time for it to
be amended but what I did do it is
brexit though isn't it because you have
been warned on this brexit do it ends
free movement of people it does allow it
though it doesn't there's a clause a
team no it's try to enforce it
trade deals it says we can stop
contributing the amount that we pay now
to the EU budget we leave the costumers
Union it might not be the Brits that you
personally want to do it but it is if
you've read it you'll see that free
movement of people has been rebranded
with a new word called mobility look if
we make some amendments of course nonces
talk today and every time it went and
every time he does this he betrays the
fact I'm not even sure he's read the
details of this himself nonetheless what
you say is basically right that we have
been so successful in shifting the
conservative party dragging the
Conservative Party kicking and screaming
to a position where they say they'll
deliver brexit and they'll cut down on
immigration numbers even though I don't
believe it I said fine we'll take him at
his word and we will stand down in those
conservative health seats and one reason
was because his language it shifted for
the second reason the even bigger reason
was I wanted to stop a second referendum
and I think the effect of a standing in
the south and the southeast would have
been two dozen plus Liberal Democrat
gains we've stopped that the where the
fundamental misunderstanding of all of
this lies in the South of England the
brexit party vote comes overwhelmingly
from conservative voters in South Wales
in the Midlands in the North our vote
comes overwhelmingly from labour voters
many of whom would never vote
conservative even
you paid them so the the ludicrous
narrative there's still a lot of
conservative voters who bake through the
North England there are some but they're
vastly outweighed by those that come
from labour and in particular those that
come from labour who will not vote how
much two-to-one roughly and most of
those seats
and here's the point the only vote
that's being split on the brexit side
are the seats in which we are
challenging labour and the Conservatives
may well split our vote at the same time
your vote has been dropping as the
campaign's gone on it - I think it's
move at all what your projected to not
get any seats at all according to the
latest you go of data practise well I
Iook then the two polls out today put
your one I think two and three plus what
I tell you what let's call this this is
laughable I mean the way the polling
industry actually operates is laughable
I promise you when you sit there and see
the results coming through in the
general election you will see that we
are on roughly 13 to 14 well I think
there's a handful in which we've got a
seriously good chance of winning and I
think we will get some in I genuinely do
well I just said to you I think was a
handful in which we really have got a
great chance of winning but our
difficulty is you know and we saw this
in the Petera by-election that our vote
too can be split by the Conservatives
and we've got to get some tactical votes
in those seats that's the battle for the
next four days it's been a difficult
week with the resignation for world well
with for any interested party
effectively saying that people should
vote conservative so we can just have a
look at what one of those people said
Annunziata Tory smug she said this week
in Scotland Wales and England the brexit
party of permitting votes to go away
from the Conservatives providing us with
an remain coalition that will do
anything not to honor the brexit
she comes in she comes from a song
brexit really well she comes from a
certain class and has always lived in
rural England and she says when she says
and she says that in her experience
brexit party supporters are by
two-to-one conservatives yes if you
knock on doors in rural England that's
what you'll find but what this shows is
a camp and I had this back in 2015 in
2015 all the commentators said you'll
split the conservative vote actually
what we did in 2015 was the damage labor
when I was lead a review kit you know we
give the Conservatives many many seats
what this shows is a complete lack of
understanding that there are now many
seats in this country where the
Conservatives are in striking distance
of winning where they would not be if
there wasn't a brexit party candidate I
mean you know Grimsby is a good example
labour down 18 points brexit party up 18
points since 2017 conservative vote
share I'm sure he couldn't be a few
weeks ago and I spoke to a few quite a
few people who said that they really
wanted to vote for the brexit party but
they won't going to because they were
really worried about a referendum
happening and so they're going to spoil
their noses and stick to the
constructive that's what I found in
Grimsby what you're seeing in Grimsby is
still a large number of people are gonna
vote brexit party and they are labour
voters who just cannot a lot of people
who vote conservative last time and then
brexit party perhaps in the US but we're
coming back I'm talking about labour
voters not conservative voters I'm
saying this to you seats like Grimsby
the Conservatives can now win because of
a number of Labour votes that we're
taking so what-what Rhys mug says here
just doesn't understand the numbers what
someone else said Shoei
Aaron banks one of your closest allies
the money's never ever backed the brexit
party since since we founded the brexit
party you know to show him in that
referendum campaign then but he doesn't
back the Bret look Aaron Banks is happy
to accept a new EU treaty I'm not
simple as that let's have a look at what
he says of you he risks splitting a vote
in something again doesn't he doesn't
understand the numbers the Lib the Lib
Dem seats would have been in South
London in Surrey
you know Dominic Rob's seat in Hampshire
and all the way down to the West Country
in the South that argument works because
in the South we take predominately
conservative votes
we're not standing in the South only in
a handful of seats of a South that were
held by Labour the Lib Dems so again
this is this is people who do not
understand because that the brexit
parties appeal just as UKIP's was in
2015 is in the labour areas we take
labour votes none of this
and you're gonna see the results as they
come to throw up on Thursday I think all
crikey this is all very surprising isn't
it I'm not going to get to the end it's
quote I can tell but it's just
irrelevant but what strikes me a little
bit to say is that why is it that so
many people who you are formerly close
to your formerly allied with douglas
Carswell
Erin banks people who've left the
Conservative Party to join the brexit
party you end up falling out with it
I've worn up anybody I haven't moved you
know I have stood and fought on
principle for 25 years and I'm doing the
same in this election of course I won't
brexit done but I want what I want
the right brexit done and I promise you
this you know I was the first to say
that mrs. May was betraying brexit
everybody laughed but I proved to be
right and I'll predict this we would be
back in crisis by June unless this
withdrawal agreement is amended and that
is the fight I've got and I want just to
get just to get a bridgehead a brexit
party MPs in Parliament to hold Boris
Johnson to account because otherwise
we're gonna see bricks it sold out are
you not worried though they're all of
these people are on banks for example
nuns er Therese morgue and others who
genuinely believe and leave an EU yeah
want to leave the EU and have campaigned
to leave and they are now saying
Nigel fraud I think but it's Breck's
Ostrom they've changed their principles
I haven't changed mine do you never
think it might be you I haven't moved
I've shifted I want us to have a clean
break from the institutions of the
European Union and if the autorai smog
stood on a ticket that said we will
leave with no deal if that's what we
have to do also stood on a mantra of
changing politics for good not
supporting it as it currently is very
quickly if we end up leaving the EU on
the January 31st
it'll have to reform into the Reform
Party it'll have to campaign to change
politics for good get rid of the House
of Lords change the voting system so
much to do and again you'll see on
Thursday a turnout much lower from the
pundits expect because people have lost
faith in politics Reform Party new name
absolutely have register already okay
thank you very much Nigel for us Nigel
Farage said the leader of the brexit
party